most people are addicted to the paycheck
and the Paycheck is one of the most
sinister plots ever pulled upon a human
being people are trying to get rich
quick stay broke long when you learn as
an investor over multiple decades is the
only thing that matters is free cash
flow that's it
wanna be happy build a life not just the
business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how you can start
your financial journey to success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one become an owner with david bach on
the game of Monopoly you go Pasco and
you get a paycheck and if you just go
around the properties and you land on
them you pay rent right and you can't
win the game Monopoly unless you buy one
green home then two green homes and
three green islands and fourth then a
hotel right like you have to be an owner
in the game of Monopoly the ironic thing
is that the game Monopoly is a great
lesson problem is for life yeah you have
to own assets that make you money while
you sleep that grow while you sleep and
the challenge for most of America is
that this stuff is not taught in school
my grandmother when she started at 30
she had nothing and she used to
literally save 50 cents a week and put
it in a coffee camp Wow and at the end
of the year she took that coffee
countdown to a brokerage firm and start
investing in stocks that's what changed
the entire destiny of my family Wow was
that my grandma at 30 with no college
education or he at Gimbels department
store Milwaukee Wisconsin got tired of
being poor there's some people watching
today that are there right there
listening they're watching the server
listening to us and they're tired of
being poor my grandmother was frustrated
and she came home I said to my
grandfather on her 30th birthday jack
this is not working like and when you're
the guy and you hear that yeah like what
do you mean this isn't working and my
grandfather said what's not working and
she said we're broke
don't have any money and you know to my
grandma's credit she decided to do
something about it
and so she literally brown bagged her
lunch every day she brown bagged her
lunch so she could save that money and
going
and the way the story turns out Louis is
my grand without my first book smart
women finish rich was dedicated her she
didn't become rich overnight she built
wealth over her lifetime yeah I always
say it's decades not days people were
trying to get rich quick stay broke long
mmm it's true like show me those banner
ads on how to get rich quick and I'll
show you a way to stay poor forever
right so my grandmother realize like you
you invest in great American companies
and you just keep investing and you
leave it and you leave and you leave it
and she helped me buy my first dog aged
7 in McDonald's Wow and that was seven
years old it was like she taught me she
taught me three lessons about money at
seven that to this day I still teach
which I can share with Alyssa so at 70
we're sitting McDonald's and she says
you know David you can get rich at
McDonald's I looked around like Grandma
I'm eating my my cheeseburger
and my french fries and I had my apple
pie I started talking about and she's
like I'm not how am I getting a job here
she's like see those people over there
they're working for what's called
minimum wage and I think back then
minimum wage was like a dollar nothing
and she said it's very hard to make a
living on minimum wage she said there's
kid people like you right now like all
these people are coming here and they're
eating and they're spending money that's
called a spender and she said then
there's some people who own this place
and owners get rich and she said you and
I love to play Monopoly at 7:00 that was
my thing I go to my grandmother and she
played Monopoly with me and she said I'm
going to teach you how to play Monopoly
for real and she took me home that day
she opened up the Wall Street Journal
she circled MCD that's the symbol still
to this day from McDonald's and she said
here's how much McDonald's is she put me
in front of a television screen and said
watch the ticker tape she taught me how
to read that ticker tape and she said
just call out the price on MCD that's
the price of McDonald's and she said
tomorrow I'll take you on her brokerage
firm will open up in a County you'll
you'll buy one share that stock and then
every time you go there you'll know
you're making money from yourself wow
that is a WoW right and it's funny
because I'm here in LA with you but I
just went to Disneyland two days ago
my son who's 9 and Disneyland Rabat
Disney I bought this that was my second
that was my second stock that's amazing
so like literally at nine I'm at Disney
with Grandma and I'm like hey Mickey are
you guys public like you know because
she taught me to think as a child like
an investor now I'm doing the same thing
with my kids no my kids don't want to
own McDonald's anyone own Shake Shack
rights so my son owns Shake Shack right
down the street right
my younger son after Disneyland was like
I want to own Disney his older brother
owns Disney it's doubled he's like well
I want to Disney my kids own Amazon so
you know they're they're learning like I
learned now this stuff should be taught
in school today this is the school right
like today what we do is another way to
teach people so but those are simple
lessons I just gave you but that were
passed to me and we just did that in a
matter of minutes
rule number two get away from the
paycheck with Robert Kiyosaki how most
people are addicted to the paycheck and
the paycheck is one of the most sinister
plots ever pulled upon a human being if
you need a paycheck you've sold your
soul you know you sold your body your
mind your spirit and your emotions you
sit there and fear of losing your job or
can I get a raise or you know will I get
promoted I mean and then and then why
would you do that and the other thing
about reason we endorse network
marketing we don't think of it as a
network marketing we think of it as
entrepreneur development because if you
need a paycheck this is not your
business
you know we build businesses so
sometimes when Kim and I do a deal we we
may not receive a paycheck for five six
years you know and so this guy's come oh
we're gonna get rich quick you know and
some people do I don't know you do or
not but that is an employee get rich
loser mindset and so the thing that
network marketing does is really gonna
cure you of the loser paycheck
get-rich-quick mentality and actually
build a business
you know we build businesses but and
that's how we're rich but we didn't get
rich quick and I don't need a paycheck I
never want a paycheck so that's kind of
a revolutionary thought to most people
up there who went to school to get good
grades and get a job you know they get a
high paying job and then the higher
paying job you you pay higher taxes and
you wonder why you never get a hit
that's because you went to school to get
a job and a paycheck you've got to get
away from the paycheck and sometimes it
might take two three years to get away
from that and that's what network
marketing teaches people
it's an entrepreneurs mindset it's a
entrepreneurs spirit not a loser
employee I need a paycheck mentality
also if you want to have more motivation
confidence and self-love check out my to
54 series they're free the link to join
on the description below what's going to
fulfill you is differently a person
actually you're not gonna learn that
from anybody else you got to find it
because success without fulfilment is
the ultimate failure you have to explain
why you're the right person to lead and
above all you have to know your numbers
I don't cheat on my wife I don't cheat
on my customers I don't cheat people I
don't cut corners if I can't do
something I'll tell you up front if I
screw up I'll tell you rule number three
diversify with Tony Robbins what would
you tell the startup entrepreneur who
maybe is just getting started maybe he
still has a full-time job and it feels
like every dollar that they're making
they're just trying to build their
business at the moment they haven't
cashed out yet should they be invested
into the business should they still be
saving some went to the market what
would you tell that person I think you
have to put something outside your
business because what's the number one
rule are the best thing that even idiots
understand
don't pull all your eggs in one basket
right and what a 90 percent of
entrepreneurs do because of the illusion
of control they go I'm gonna put all my
money in my business don't get me wrong
it's still a great place for your money
after your time with your energy but you
got to take a piece of what you earn and
you gotta bet on some other
entrepreneurs you get outside yourself
specifically and if you look at you know
somebody like Warren Buffett I'll sell
you you know what he said my all my
wealth as a result of a couple things
some good genes and compound interest
and living in America so if all you do
is get compound
on your side the game changes you take a
19 year old kid it's got a little job
and you say look I want you it sounds
like a lot but I want to put aside three
hundred dollars a month let me show you
why
three two bucks a month set aside throw
it in the market average market returns
been eight percent spent ten percent of
hundred years but most recent you know
thirty years eight percent so let's say
you get the average return that
compounds that kid who starts at
nineteen with three hundred a month can
stop at twenty seven
he's only done it for eight years never
put another dime in and he's only put in
twenty four twenty eight thousand
dollars but that'll grow to 1.8 million
without putting him in a diamond that's
the power of compounding 28 grand 1.8
million if his best friend starts at 27
when he quits and the best every single
year all the way to 65 and he puts in
the same three hundred dollars a month
he puts in 140 grand and in that time
he's got four hundred thousand dollars
less money so it's not the amount of
money it's the amount of time time is
your greatest friend here and if you get
in the game you're gonna win and you
need to get the game now not wait to
your business to success
I know number four the last one before a
very special bonus clip is focus on the
cash flow with Kevin O'Leary
what's the value of a stock that never
returns capital to its shareholders I
don't know because the only way you can
make money is if somebody else is
willing to buy that position at a higher
price for some emotional reason perhaps
or for some you know foresight that
maybe the company will return capital
one day and I think of it you know what
when you learn as an investor over
multiple decades is the only thing that
matters is free cash flow that's it
there is no other reason to own a stock
and with that philosophy it brings you
into a place where you focus on a
company's ability to generate
incremental cash flow because just
owning a dividend paying stock is not
good enough because you know let's say
we find a stock today that's paying a
three percent dividend yield and
tomorrow because it's forecast for sales
get cut in half the stock drops by 50
percent now it's yielding six percent I
don't want to own that stock either so
my tests in this
index that I've you know created with
let's see Russell looks at the balance
sheet every year we test to make sure
that the company is viable in its
ability to generate cash this is
extremely conservative investing this is
for the long haul these tools are not
for as you're suggesting for spicy you
know the hot stock does your I've done
that I've been there you know let the
young legs do I have zero interest in
that I don't care what the hot new stock
is you know when a company comes public
I won't own it either it's got to prove
to me over multiple years that it can
continue to generate cash before it even
fits into what I'm doing so I'm really
boring and I like it that way
I'm guessing it came from your mother
but what would you say was the best
piece of financial advice or business
advice you ever got in your long lengthy
career when I was seven and my brother
was five she'd take us to the bank with
her you know
because that's where you would buy bonds
back in those days you could actually
buy the certificate with the coupons
every six months you clip them off she'd
say to his boys never spend the
principal only the interest I had no
idea what she was talking about that's
all I do today in my world you never
touch a principal you adjust your
spending habits your gifts to charities
your use of capital based on how much
you can generate from your portfolio I
view my portfolio and my trust and my
positions as a chicken on a spit
dripping cash everything has to generate
yield whether it's a fixed income
position or inequity it has to it the
only reason it can be in my world is
generating capital back to me I take
that I disperse it the family lives off
that the charities I've committed to so
I'm always looking for a company that
can help me with my problem of
generating more yield everything that I
mean I can't even imagine buying a stock
that doesn't pay a difference why would
you do that what would it be the reason
you would do that I don't get it so to
me that means about 28% of the market to
me is just speculation a stuff that
doesn't pay a dividend is a speculation
it's not an investment
now I have a special bonus clip with Dan
lock on how to talk about money that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go
question number one where do you need to
become an owner number two how can you
get away from the paycheck and there
were three what will you do this week to
focus on cash flow money moves to those
who are not afraid to talk about it
people ask me all the time Dan why they
talk about money all the time you see
there's nothing wrong or evil about
money money is neutral imagine if you
enjoy talking about basketball
Raptors NBA Canadian team right if you
enjoy playing basketball or watching
basketball would you be ashamed to talk
about basketball with your friends your
buddies no you wouldn't
then why would you be ashamed talking
about money you see you have a story in
your mind right now about health about
success about life and also about money
you have a story in your mind right now
and guess who created those stories
could be your parents could be your
relatives it could be the people that
you know you're loved you're brought in
sisters you're cousins
it doesn't matter but you picked up
those stories from somewhere remember
when you were a little kid the horror
story the scary story the spooky story
the boogeyman hiding the closet someone
planted those thoughts in your mind and
someone planted those thoughts about
money in your mind as well that it's
hard to get money that rich people are
bad that you have to do something bad to
to make money and and it's one thing to
make money and it's very difficult to
keep money and if you make the money and
now you lose it then you look really
really stupid but it's simply not true
the people who are struggling with money
they afraid to talk about money and
believe me they do talk about money the
difference is they argue all the money
do your parents argue over money do you
argue over money with the
one your spouse your boyfriend and
girlfriend I remember one of the few
times in my life that I saw my mom cried
was because we ran out of money so
remember money secret number one money
moves to those who are not afraid to
talk about it
what's the difference between
billionaires and the rest of the world
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
trying to Bowl the company and have it
succeed is like eating glass and staring
into the abyss I was never the one to
like chase the sector oh this is hot
because you have to ask yourself